The Joe Rogan Experience they'll
probably do something like they're doing
with John like have a super card but
only have to pay out you know one
Champion so I'm assuming they'll
probably do something like that it's
funny that you think about that way
because I've been thinking like that
until you said that I never considered
it oh yeah that other fight neither one
of those guys is a current world
champion even though it's for the title
yep they don't get a piece of the
pay-per-view I've been I've been
thinking I've been having like a
business kind of mindset getting the
fighting early early on like thinking
about numbers and brand deals and and
when I get to this position what I'm
going to ask for at the UFC and because
I go and sit down with Hunter and and do
our own uh negotiations and stuff and
it's fun I enjoy that aspect of fighting
I enjoy the business side of it to where
a lot of Fighters don't they're like
here I'll just pay someone to [__] do
it do it for me but I've always been
excited about that I've always wanted to
be in the entrepreneur type stuff well
that's great that you enjoy it because
for some Fighters it's like a labor yeah
you know and they don't do it but if
you're excited about it that's awesome
because that's definitely a smart thing
and you know just the ability to promote
just promoting fights like that is such
a factor there's so many guys that are
really talented but for whatever reason
the Public's not captivated by them and
so they just never quite hit their
potential in terms of like Revenue yeah
for sure
I mean it's crazy now with all the
social media guys fighting now and
making Banks
pretty amazing so is that Dylan Dana's
fight off with Logan I saw him tweet
[__] him out piece or something but
then I seen someone confirm that he had
he hadn't he didn't act he didn't pull
out but that [__] he's been
calling us since the day where he said
there's no way that motherfucker's
showing up
but they haven't pulled out yet well if
he doesn't show up how is he making
money that's what I was wondering that's
what I was wondering I don't know if
can't take a break
uh off Twitter without people thinking
I'm pulling out well his [__] tweet
yeah he's a great troll yeah he is he's
good it's he's doing I mean well for a
guy that's last time he fought was in
Bellator like when how long yeah
probably four or five years ago but for
Logan's girl to sue him
lawsuits lawyers that [__] there's
nothing more [__] stressful and
frustrating than that going through that
stuff and Dylan Pratt doesn't have a lot
of cheddar so now he's getting sued he
has to hire a lawyer and those lawyer
bills add the [__] up so I bet he's
[__] stressing look at this he's
sparring with Alex pajeda
that's very interesting yeah Alex being
real nice to him yeah real nice by the
way yeah real nice and you know you're
only going to learn so much in a certain
amount of time right I mean it's not
like Dylan is an absolutely terrible
Striker yeah but he's not a striker he's
an elite Grappler his grappling is
[__] amazing I mean he's really
[__] good yeah on the ground he's
Sensational that kid has some [__]
serious Jujitsu but it's just he's not
known for being a boxer no it's like the
Ben Aston situation yeah you know Jake
Paul offers you more money probably than
he made his entire UFC career for a
boxing match after you've had a hip
replacement you're like [__] it I'm in
so he comes in looking like a guy who
delivers milk we were there gutting tits
oh yeah that was crazy